so with mondays including our marvel
what if story what i want to do here is
i want to cover the story of the
incredible hulk killing all the
superheroes
and becoming a herald of galactus this
is kind of like the worst case scenario
for earth and it's actually a lot more
complicated than it seems in terms of
all the stuff that happens meaning it's
not like a linear series of events
there's all kinds of crazy stuff that
goes on in the story it's one of the
reasons why i love it so much but this
story comes directly out of
uh the world war hulk storyline now for
those of you guys who don't know and i
know there's a lot of people out there
that do but for those of you guys who
don't know
when it came to the world war hulk story
this was basically just a way to remove
the incredible hulk
from the marvel landscape prior to civil
war and then bring him back
and so what marvel did is they basically
had a group called the illuminati
charles xavier blackbold of the inhumans
name of the submariner dr strange
they had the group come to the decision
that the incredible hulk was just too
unpredictable and violent to remain on
earth
and ended up sending him into space the
problem was he ended up traveling
through
a uh through a wormhole more or less
ended up on the wrong side of the galaxy
and landed on
a place called sikar which led into the
planet hulk event whereby he basically
rallied together a whole bunch of
revolutionary forces and was able to
topple the existing king the issue with
this was that while those people who
looked to the incredible hulk as the
savior
were in the midst of building a monument
the ship that he was sent on by the
illuminati was detonated accidentally
and set off a thermal nuclear blast and
in doing so
he basically killed the incredible
hulk's new wife their unborn child or i
guess their their newborn child
and uh you know basically everybody that
the hulk knew uh on the new kingdom that
he had settled for himself and so
because of this
he returned back to earth with what he
called his war bound his pact of people
that he had uh come to view his allies
during his time as a gladiator during
the planet hulk storyline
and he basically cut a swath through the
superhero community now what this does
is this shows us an alternate situation
because this brings in
the events of secret invasion now secret
invasion was another half of the marvel
storyline that was a series of events
whereby marvel established that these
skrulls who had the ability to
shapeshift had previously had their
planet destroyed by
by a galactus and they had looked to
earth as a new home for themselves in a
manifest destiny kind of situation and
the result was that they had begun the
process
of replacing the various occupants human
and superhero alike on earth with scroll
replicants the issue with this was that
during this part of the story of world
war hulk
the scroll queen is basically
spider-woman jessica drew
and so because of this she's still on
earth and these scrolls are effectively
just waiting out in space for her to
give the signal for them to all show up
and uh and invade the planet earth and
basically kill off all the superheroes
but what happens here is that unlike the
original uh world war hook event with
reed richards
creating these satellites that would
basically attack the incredible hulk and
destroy him
because of the fact that the battle is
going so badly because bruce banner is
literally just tearing
all the superheroes apart piece by piece
it's really like
a last-ditch effort it's really just you
know just wipe everything out just you
know it's a scorched earth kind of
policy
and so what happens is that as the at
the request of reed richards tony stark
launches the satellites
and annihilates everybody and so the
most powerful superheroes who are going
against uh bruce banner are all
annihilated in this destruction
or in this in this conflict and so what
we do is we actually jump forward
by a few months in the sense that the
bishop where the queen having been
killed among all these heroes her uh
second in command her bishop who's kind
of like this religious leader in the
scroll empire
takes control of the scroll fleet and
begins invading the planet earth and so
what we do is we switch to what what
seems to be a few months and we end up
joining with
a recreated version of the vision and
the vision shows up
and discovers that bruce banner is
basically digging graves for everyone
who died
in new york whether they were human
whether they were superhero he's in the
middle of building all this now of
course bruce banner can't really survive
the high level of radiation here
which is one of the other reasons why
those those survivors who weren't
obliterated by the blast were almost
immediately killed off by the radiation
because it was so potent but he finds
that bruce banner's here and he
basically begins talking with him right
he's like hey look man you know
um we need you like we basically need
you here now bruce banner doesn't want
to have anything to do with this he says
you know
yes i could survive in my hook form but
i'm basically dying you know and this is
bruce banner just kind of coming to
terms
with the destruction that he's that he's
experienced over the course of his life
all the destruction that he's basically
created
and so it's him paying penance so it's
very similar to the incredible hulk last
man on earth storyline that we had
previously covered
but what the vision says is look man
like this was not the end like these
superheroes this was in the end while
you've been here in isolation in new
york you know the skrulls invaded earth
and they almost immediately killed off
the x-men whatever superheroes were left
were
second tier at best wolverine was
removed from the planet earth because
his healing factor made him immortal so
the only way to basically
keep him from killing off the scrolls in
their entirety was to just take him away
from earth so they you know so they
don't have to worry about him here and
the result is that there's only like a
handful
of us left there's almost nobody left
alive we have hank
hank pym we have janet van dyne we have
a couple others here and there
cannonball sam guthrie but they're
really just
scavengers survivors the ones who've
been trying to make it day by day and
we're rallying them to our cause and
this is kind of the cool thing is
because he says you know
janet van dyne is the one that brought
them all together janet van dyne was the
person that said look we need
leadership here now what most likely
happened this is kind of what we're left
to
to figure out on our own devices anyway
what most likely happened behind the
scenes was that hank pym really probably
just had like a crisis of conscience
that's not new for his character hey pam
has emotional breakdowns all the time he
has emotional breakdowns with regards to
his personalities he has multiple
multiple breakdowns with regards to
you know whether or not the super bowl
is going the way that he wants it to he
has emotional breakdowns for everything
it's insane
and so because of this uh janet van daan
probably stepped up and really took the
reins and so what happens is we
basically transition to a base uh in the
andreonics i think it's what it's called
andrea dax and it's basically a section
of the world whereby some heroes or some
some survivor some humans are trying to
take refuge but they're being tracked
down systematically by the scrolls and
so while hank pam while sam guthrie do
what they can to rescue
these people they're suddenly met by the
arrival of bruce banner the incredible
hook now what's also cool about this is
that bucky barnes is alive uh now this
is during the time when bucky barnes
at least it seems as though he was
underground and so it you know for some
reason or another obviously probably the
conflict with the incredible hulk
brought him back but whatever the case
may be here he's also one of the
military guys who's kind of running the
show
and we would expect that with uh with
bucky barnes if janet van dyne is the
one who's in charge of everything she
would have to have generals people who
would basically go out
and overwatch field missions and because
bucky barnes spends so much time
fighting alongside captain america it
makes perfect sense that he would be one
of the people who would oversee this
conflict but when the incredible hulk
arrives
bucky barnes initially finds it a little
strange because when they get back
to the to an abandoned shield bunker
most likely having belonged to nick fury
and you know operating as a new base of
the avengers when they get back there
you know bucky barnes initially says
this is gonna be strange and the reason
is because
everybody doesn't like the hulk like a
lot of people just hate him because he
was the one that led to this in the
first place you know the incredible hoax
rampage on the planet earth the fact
that he cut a swath through so many
different superheroes
and basically set up the stage for the
scrolls to take advantage of a fractured
earth and in doing so
conquer it and so what happens is the
incredible hulk actually turncoats and
says hey look guys
you know i'm here to try to save things
i'm here to fix things you know because
of all the destruction
the destruction that i've robbed because
of all the conflict that i've created
i'm here to try to try to atone for that
and make up for my past mistakes and so
alongside
you know uh dagger alongside you know
bucky barnes
a whole horde of superheroes they
literally just start
tearing through the scrolls everywhere i
mean they just start conquering
you know conquering uh cities you know
they start conquering outposts they
start freeing all these different people
and so when it gets to the point whereby
the scrolls are starting to realize that
the incredible hulk is working against
them and that with his unbridled
strength there's really nothing they can
do to stop him
the scroll bishop says it's time to
enact our spy he says we have a spy
among the ranks of these superheroes and
it's time to bring them out now one of
his one of his generals says well why
did you wait this long you know why did
you wait so long like we've lost
hundreds of people
why did you wait until just now to enact
this spy and to bring them down and this
is actually really really smart the
bishop says because i wanted all the
heroes in one spot now that's that's the
smart thing because you know the heroes
were either in camps or they were hiding
whatever the case may have been
not all of them were gathered together
as part of the part of the new avengers
and so the bishop said look the
incredible hulk
is a is a force of nature if he allies
himself with the avengers
his strength will give other people
strength and as a result they'll come
out of hiding they'll rally under the
umbrella of his capabilities and they'll
literally
you know create their own their own team
and they'll launch a war against us and
so he says
when they do that then that will be when
all the heroes come out and that's when
we strike
and so what we learn is that the skrull
replicant that's been
a part of the avengers this entire time
was janet van dyne and janet van dyne
had been put there as that scroll
replacement
since the beginning of the conflict
since you know almost immediately after
uh you know the the incredible hulk i
guess immediately after the destruction
of tony stark when it came to new york
city and so as a result she says the
scrolls had basically analyzed the
genome
of uh hank pym and they found that he
was effectively unstable in terms of his
molecular structure
because of the pym particles and so she
said what they could do is they could
basically turn him
into a genetic bomb they could
effectively detonate him on the
molecular level and they could let off a
massive wave of destruction and that's
exactly what happens with all the heroes
being there in one place they quite
literally just
detonate hank pym and in doing so it's
this massive
you know i guess what would amount to a
nuclear explosion and it annihilates
every single hero who's there and so in
effect
the incredible hulk is the last man on
earth right now i mean all the humans
who were rallied in the bunker of the
new avengers are dead you know all those
existing uh
humans are gone all the superheroes that
remained on earth that were in this
bunker
are gone and so because of this the
incredible hulk just wants to see the
earth destroyed so what happens
is the incredible hulk recalls an
instance whereby when he was on the
defenders alongside silver surfer and
um doctor strange he recalls that they
were informed by reed richards that
there is
a homing device a beacon in a pocket of
the negative zone some little small
aspect of the negative zone it can be
accessed using
you know whatever portals it was that
existed in what was left of the baxter
building and the incredible hulk could
access this beacon and use it to call
the silver surfer and so silver surfer
arrives here
and when he does the incredible hulk
says wipe out the earth call galactus
and have him consume the earth now this
is crazy because we've never really seen
an instance where a superhero
says we want galactus to wipe out the
earth of course then again a lot of
that's because the superheroes don't
want their earth destroyed but even in a
lot of like the post-apocalyptic what-if
scenarios for example the incredible
hulk being the last man
on earth when all the the population of
heroes and humans are wiped out in a
global nuclear war you know surely this
was a scenario he could have called and
he could have just had the
had you know galactus consume the earth
and destroy him but of course that story
needed to take a different tone and it
was written at a different point in time
too
so it may just be that you know for
whatever reason reed richards never told
them about this homing beacon that would
bring galactus in but the only time
we've ever really seen
an instance where something like this
has happened it was during jonathan
hickman's fantastic four
when you know reed richards realized
that there was going to be a massive
conflict of the planet earth and
summoned galactus to fight on his behalf
against the mad celestials that was
really the only time we've ever really
seen that happen and so the incredible
hulk here is is just
unbridled rage and so silver surfer says
okay fine because right now the
incredible hulk will kill him if the
silver surfer doesn't do it the
incredible hulk will kill him and that's
entirely possible
the hulk's durability his strength makes
him you know well beyond the silver
surfer when it comes to just
sheer force now the silver server can do
all kinds of crazy things too he could
probably break down the hulk
on a molecular level you know he could
wipe him out of existence he could do a
lot of different things but when it
comes to this moment right now with the
incredible hulk's hands around the
silver surfer's neck
he would kill him he would literally
just just kill him on the spot so the
silver surface says okay fine if you
want your earth destroyed i'll destroy
it and i'll have galactus destroy you're
the last human here so you're really the
only one that's in a fit place to judge
what happens and so the silver surfer
says not only will i bring galactus here
and have him consume the earth i'm
leaving i'm not going to be a herald of
galactus this is the last straw and so
the silver surfer basically takes off
now of course we follow up with this
with galactus arriving on earth with his
machine
and uh basically destroying the earth
which is kind of ironic
because galactus destroying the the
scroll home world is the reason why the
scrolls showed up on earth in the first
place and so it's really just history
repeating itself but following the
destruction of this earth the
destruction of the superheroes all of
which was led to by the actions of the
incredible
hulk we end up having him met with
galactus and galactus says
look my herald is gone i have no one
here to fight on my behalf i have no one
here
to find these you know find planners for
me to consume i am going to make you my
new herald i'm going to make you the guy
who's going to be the one that goes out
and finds these planets for me now the
problem with the incredible hulk is that
for him
he wanted he wanted to die he didn't
want to you know he wanted the earth
destroyed because he wanted to be
destroyed with it for him his actions
his violence his conflict his
destruction had
led to the deaths of all the superheroes
that he had ever known it led to the
death of all of humanity and so for him
he wanted an end to the whole damn thing
he wanted the scrolls destroyed because
they killed superheroes and they took
over the earth and then he wanted to die
because he was the source of all the
the suffering that he had ever
experienced in his life but galactus
says
no not only that i'm not going to make
you live a new life remembering
everything that had happened
i'm going to make you forget i'm going
to wipe your memory of everything that
had ever happened this is going to be a
clean slate and you are going to go
forward
as my herald in the universe with no
realization of who you were
before this moment and that's exactly
what happens the incredible hulk
becomes the herald of galactus and
presumably goes about the world you know
doing whatever is it
or going about the universe doing
whatever it is he does as far as i know
there's no follow-up series to this this
is just this is it which if there was a
follow-up series and if there is
somebody post a comment let me know
because i want to make videos on that
i want to make videos on the incredible
hulk as a herald of galactus that would
be so
beast like post a comment like if you
guys would want to see something like
that post a comment if it exists i'll
make a video on you know the first story
arc or something like that but uh
yeah so anyway that's the story the
incredible hulk becoming a herald
galactus he
like his entire life led to the
destruction of all the superheroes not
to mention his violence and rage
and with everything dead with all humans
and all superheroes dead galactus just
makes him his herald so if you guys are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the subscribe button if you
guys uh
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and leave a comment down below let
me know what you guys think and i will
catch you all later
peace you know here's a crazy thing
where i say that i've been reading
marvel comics for you know 20 something
years a huge bulk of that
has been the x-men i mean i always loved
the x-men they were just my favorite
team like they were one of my favorite
groups really that existed in marvel
comics i read other stuff just out of
curiosity about what it was about but
like the meat and potatoes of most of my
knowledge when it comes to marvel comics
is the x-men
and this story is amazing it's sad
but it's really really amazing so the
juggernaut of course is one of the more
popular foes of the x-men i mean in a
lot of ways i would argue he's more of
the arch nemesis of charles xavier by
extension the x-men but magneto is still
probably the most popular villain when
people think of like
the main enemy of the x-men they think
of magneto and rightfully so i mean he
was the first major villain they faced
but with regards to juggernaut
he's always been this sort of wrecking
ball he's not very smart
but his history with his step-brother uh
charles xavier created a lot of
animosity between the two and so because
of the fact that they bickered and they
argued and kane marco hated charles once
he became the juggernaut you know during
the korean war when he picked up the
crimson gem of sidorak and you know he
got that whole
transcription you know whosoever touches
this gym shall receive the power of the
crimson bands of sidorak or whatever it
is henceforth you who read these words
shall go forevermore a human juggernaut
something along those lines i'm
paraphrasing but the fact remains once
he became the juggernaut he was like
this unstoppable force and it was kind
of cool because in marvel comics the
juggernaut literally lives up to his
words in almost every conceivable way
there was for example a time where the
incredible hulk defeated the juggernaut
didn't really defeat him but managed to
push him back which was supposed to be
impossible
but it took the incredible hulk modified
with celestial technology at the hands
of apocalypse in order to make that
happen again that all goes into the
nature of the fact that sidorak is one
of these old demonic entities that
exists in marvel comics
it's a wildly powerful being but in
terms of the juggernaut he's an avatar
as if sidorak were walking around the
world now juggernaut's not nearly as
powerful as sidorak but it's still kind
of cool because what this story does is
it basically comes after the events of
x-men number 11 back in 1965 written by
stan lee and jack kirby
now the idea behind x-men number 11 is
that it basically introduced this i'm
pretty sure it introduced the character
of the stranger and the stranger is just
one of those cosmic entities that exists
out there and he's literally
called a stranger because nothing's
known about him he's just a being who's
there
he's got cosmic powers and that's really
about it but in that story the stranger
had shown up on earth and basically
kidnapped magneto in the toad
and whisked them off to his own planet
just to explore and you know just study
them and so it was kind of cool
in terms of how that little bit a little
bit worked but what this story does is
it takes place in the interim when
magneto is off planet alongside toad and
it initially opens up with this bit of
an explanation
all the avengers are dead thor's dead
iron man's dead captain america's death
and standing over them all
is the juggernaut now the initial
indication here is that the juggernaut's
the one that did them all in but then we
end up finding out that it was actually
the sentinels that basically killed off
all these different superheroes and it's
kind of cool when we get to see like
juggernaut versus the sentinels because
one thing to keep in mind
is that different writers interpret the
powers of characters differently
and it's all contextual and based on
what story they want to tell
for example in this story juggernaut
rips through these signals i mean it's
no challenge at all
he's got super strength he's virtually
unstoppable once he stops moving once he
starts moving he's
nigh indestructible one of them makes a
comment they have like
less than one percent of a chance to
actually survive the experience like one
ten
thousandth or one one hundred thousandth
of a percent and surviving the
experience and so it's kind of cool
because when they try to take off
juggernaut grabs him basically kind of
drags him back down
and uh and you know completely and
totally pummels him but if we go and
read a story like days of future past
that was a story chris claremont wrote
an uncanny x-men 141-142 i think it was
and it was basically
the worst case scenario it was an answer
to the question what would happen if
mutants failed
if xavier was killed and senator robert
kelly was killed what would happen if
they were assassinated by mutants and
what would happen if humanity responded
by jump starting the sentinel program
and the sentinels went awry it was a
doomsday scenario it was the worst case
situation
for earth and more for the mutants than
anything else because they failed in
their entirety and so the days of future
past led to the seminals more or less
modifying their own programming becoming
autonomous and then just wiping out the
entirety of humanity mutants and
otherwise and that was really about it i
mean you had a few
little you know rebel factions here and
there and of course that led into you
know rachel summers the daughter of jean
grey and cyclops from days of future
past sending the mind of kitty pride
into the past to stop the whole thing
from happening but still
the idea was that you know signals had
basically conquered earth and so when
you go and you read that story
juggernaut's long since been dead he was
eradicated by the symbols and
consolidating those two things is kind
of difficult because if his power was
has basically always been the same
if for the most part up until eighth day
up until try on his powers were
basically
consistent across the board then how do
you justify those two things and there's
really no way that you can you just kind
of have to roll with the punches and
just say hey look just the way it goes
different writers want to tell different
stories but the cool thing about this is
that juggernaut gives us a lot of inner
monologue
in terms of how he views things in the
sense that the juggernaut was always
very selfishly motivated in a lot of
ways i mean he had a few friends here
and there like black tom cassidy for
example you know who for the most part
resided in cassidy keep but for the most
part
juggernaut was largely just kind of a
lone wolf out there by himself
doing whatever it is that he wanted to
do because he could he was more or less
a bully who received these almost
godlike powers in terms of strength
durability speed
movement different things like that and
so as a result you know with him
basically losing everybody believing
that everybody out there is completely
and totally dead
he actually goes back to the xavier
institute and this is very human
of kane marco i mean he is human in and
of himself he just has incredible powers
by way of the gym but he almost seems
inhuman in terms of how he acts
no one can stop the juggernaut he's this
unstoppable force he doesn't seem to be
human but then when he shows up here he
basically has this sort of connection
with charles xavier his argument is yes
i hated them yes i hated the x-men yes i
hated charles xavier but i would do
anything to be able to talk to them
again because
i am just so absolutely lonely he misses
his connection with humanity because
it's the one thing that he never really
seemed to have before you know and so
because of this what he ends up doing is
he basically ends up walking the earth
for like days
and weeks and years time just passes it
just sort of blurs together and all he
can do is just travel around the world
and look at all these different shambles
bits and pieces these relics of humanity
and so you know finally he comes across
this old sentinel base that he long
since destroyed and the symbols begin
coming to life
only for us to realize they're being
controlled by magneto and so this is
cool because this is how this feeds in
to x-men issue number 11. in exponential
number 11 and that story written in 1965
magneto managed to finally get out you
know managed to to basically make his
way back to earth in this story events
unfolded almost the exact same way in
the sense that magneto is being studied
by the stranger but he also gained
access to a lot of the different
devices that the stranger had as a
cosmic entity he's come across all
different manner of devices from
different alien races things he's made
on his own
and what these things allowed magneto to
do was basically look at the earth and
see what was going on and what we end up
finding out here is that when the
sentinels began their campaign and they
started going around and killing all
these different superheroes that from
magneto's perspective juggernaut just
kind of watched it all unfold he just
basically
stood back and watched it all happen
while juggernaut didn't necessarily kill
the avengers or the x-men himself his
inaction allowed it to happen but then
we get like this massive revelation what
we end up finding out is that somewhere
along the line
when juggernaut presumably first you
know became a major villain for the
x-men
uh he showed up at the xavier institute
and he basically
killed all the x-men not only that you
know when he killed the x-men when he
killed charles xavier the whole nine
yards when the sentinel program was
reinitiated when it all jump started
again there was nobody there to warn the
avengers to warn the fantastic four the
signals just kind of popped up out of
nowhere and where the x-men have
consistently fought the sentinels and
where the x-men are best
suited to defeat the signals because of
their knowledge about the sentinel's
design
the x-men weren't there because
juggernaut killed them and so because of
that there was no one left to defend
humanity there was nobody left there to
save humans and so as the signals began
going through and wiping out humans what
sentinels began to realize
is that humans do procreate at a
ridiculous rate and so because of that
it would basically take
too long and the earth would be almost
eradicated in its entirety virtually
uninhabitable if the campaign went on
and so what they ended up doing was in
an effort to basically eliminate as many
humans as possible they basically
modified their own cells to emit a kind
of radiation and so the earth itself is
just blanketed and all this radiation
and that's what killed all the humans
that's what killed everybody it was
basically the juggernaut who killed the
x-men which led to the deaths of almost
everything in existence but the reason
why i say almost
is because in the juggernaut's rage at
this revelation the fact that he's the
one that basically led
to everything coming to an end he starts
freaking out stomping on the ground only
to fall down into this cavern and
discover the iceman bobby drake now this
is kind of cool
in terms of how this feeds on iceman's
history historically speaking bobby
drake has always been a little bit
reckless and a little bit just sort of
headstrong and more of the jokester than
anything else he's very much
indicative of like your stereotypical
teenager you know and because of that he
never really applied himself the way
that he needed to now that also went
into the idea of why it is that bobby
drake was so popular but with him
failing to basically
focus and harness his abilities the way
that he should because this is
relatively early in the days of the
x-men this meant that once charles
xavier died there was no one there to
teach bobby drake how to use his powers
and so for the most part he can't
control his abilities
and in this instance you know where he
says i can only maintain this current
form
for a few moments at a time the amount
of time that he maintains it goes on too
long and he basically encases himself in
ice
and he can't get out he can't shut his
powers down but because of the fact that
bobby drake had basically made reference
to the fact that there are people here
juggernaut and his desire to see more of
humanity and his desire to experience a
connection
smashes through bobby drake and then
smashes through the door
and of course when he shows up we end up
finding out that characters like
quicksilver are alive
scarlet witch is alive toad who's
basically sort of this jokey henchman of
uh of magneto we're alive and there's a
few other mutants here and there but
there's also a lot of people
and that's kind of the irony of all this
because what toad tells us is that when
magneto came back to earth
and realized the sentinels were
basically running amok they were wiping
out humanity in the process wiping out
whatever mutants were left basically
killing everything they could find
magneto and toad grabbed as many people
as they could human or mutant threw him
into their ship and then whisked them
off to this location to basically create
a safe haven of sorts and so with this
this radiation spreading throughout the
world they effectively created a bunker
that protected them from it but the
irony is that with juggernaut showing up
and juggernaut smashing down the door in
his effort to experience and to talk to
more people he
doomed them all to death he's basically
doomed the last remnants of humanity and
mutants
to die at the hands of this toxic
radiation because he wanted to see them
so badly and that goes into the nature
of the juggernaut right i mean he leaps
before he looks and he doesn't think
about what's actually happened he just
does things and then whatever happens
happens and so despite the fact that he
was longing for a connection that he
actually broke into this place
intending no ill will he dooms what's
left of humanity he basically killed
everybody on earth and so it's kind of
cool
because in this scenario he's basically
forced to just sort of walk off
live just kind of exists because he
doesn't need food he doesn't need water
he's effectively immortal so long as
he's
in possession of the crimson gem the
juggernaut is the last man on earth
that's it there's no one left the last
vestiges the last little tidbits of
whoever was alive were in that bunker
and they're all dying now i mean they're
they've got minutes and so because of
that he's just doomed to walk the earth
forever until the earth's destruction or
it's repopulated or
whatever the case may be and so again
it's pretty dark and it's pretty messed
up
to me it's one of the coolest juggernaut
stories that's out there so with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace so continuing our videos on
marvel's what if
series with doctor strange right around
the corner what i wanted to do here
is dip my toe in the water and have a
discussion about
what would have happened if dr doom
became dr strange now a couple things to
bear in mind here for those of you guys
who are new
to marvel comics and new to my channel
the what if line of stories are
publications designed to offer
us alternate reality depictions of
events that is to say
you know in this instance dr doom
becoming doctor strange instead of
stephen strange in addition to this this
story was written by dan slott and so
like all dance slot stories
it makes sense in the beginning and then
it goes off the rails about halfway
through and i don't know what was going
on with dan slott when he wrote this if
he was just relatively new i feel like
he was
but he went completely off the
reservation about halfway through this
story but what we do here
is we pick up with dr doom encountering
the ancient one for the very first time
now this is this is actually really kind
of cool
because this ties directly into the
history of dr doom and what i mean
is for those of you guys who have seen
my series on the books of doom we talked
about his his life as a child that he
had uh witnessed his mother's murder
that he had witnessed his father's
murder that he had basically gone to uh
north america
because of his vast intelligence he was
inducted into new york state university
where he met reed richards but his
mother's soul had been captured by
mephisto due to the fact that she had
invoked a pack
with the prince of lies i guess are with
the demon for the purpose of granting
her
the abilities related to black magic and
the result of this was that her soul was
doomed forever to remain in the clutches
of mephisto
and doctor doom himself had basically
spent as much of his life as he could
trying to find ways to free his mother's
soul now after creating a teleporter
that allowed him to travel to the nether
realm in an attempt to save his mother's
life
in the process he had basically
destroyed his face and the result was
that an attempt to pursue a cure for
this as well as gain the power necessary
to free his mother's soul
instead of traveling to the himalayas
and stumbling upon a temple of monks
he instead had traveled to tibet and he
had stumbled upon
the temple of the ancient one with
regards to the original sorcerer supreme
and so because of this
when the ancient one had basically asked
dr doom what he what it was that he was
there for
the ancient one also heard or i guess uh
scanned the mind and the heart and soul
of doctor doom and discovered that he
was basically looking for power that he
wasn't really looking to make the world
a better place he wasn't really looking
to operate outside of himself
in terms of being altruistic instead he
just wanted to amass power and the
result was that the ancient one was
actually pretty hesitant to help doctor
doom but
the ancient one also realized that there
was a flicker of
you know greatness in victor von doom
and the ancient one believed that he
could turn that flicker into a full-on
flame
and make doctor doom somebody
spectacular so what happened was
he basically took victor under his wing
and began teaching him everything he
knew the problem with this was that for
baron mordo
uh the you know at that point in time
the protege of the ancient one he viewed
doctor doom as a threat simply because
of the fact that doom was able to
learn in days what it took bear and
mordo to learn
in weeks and months and so because of
this victor is
wildly more powerful than baron mordo
now much like the
uh you know maine marvel timeline where
steven strange and baron mordo had
formed a rivalry of sorts
baron mordo also tries to attack victor
von doom
but what happens is that when he sees
his face he actually discovers
that it is a doombot now dan's slot does
not square this circle you know
for those of you guys who don't know
victor von doom did not start creating
doombots uh really until after he became
victor von doom or at least doombots as
we knew them when he was
at you know new york state university
and what i mean here is that while
doctor doom was creating doombots while
he was at
uh empire state university the issue is
that we're not told how this doombot got
here we're not told how it managed to
make its way in here with no
one knowing maybe he teleported it
whatever the case may be but the fact
remains
that this doombot also housed within it
a small tube and within this tube
is a basically a bomb on the subatomic
scale that dr doom plants in the brain
of baron mordo basically stating that if
baron mordo kills doctor doom or
if doctor doom feels as though he's
being betrayed he can activate the
device and it'll kill baron mordo and so
one of the interesting things about this
is the ancient one initially appears to
victor von doom after he makes this
threat and doesn't realize that victor
von doom was telling the truth instead
the ancient one thinks he's bluffing the
ancient one thinks that he's basically
lying and so what happens is
shortly after this dr doom comes to the
realization that the ancient one could
easily be toppled because you know this
this guy does not realize the
advancement of technology in relation to
what doom
is capable of now following this
particular plan that doom begins to lay
in motion
we ultimately pick up with the arrival
of stephen strange now the arrival of
stephen strange happens exactly the way
it did
in marvel comics and this is interesting
because victor von doom
his timeline started before steven
strange that's to say
doom was at school with reed richards
doom experienced his face being scarred
before steven strange experienced his
car wreck which resulted in him
traveling to
the temple of the ancient one and
looking for a cure you know to basically
restore his ability to use his hands and
become a surgeon again but
because of the fact that doom is a
student of the ancient one when
stephen strange arrives here he's
basically met with victor von doom and
when steven strange says that his whole
purpose for being here is to find a cure
so that he can continue to use his hands
and to be a neurosurgeon instead
instead of allowing him to become a part
of the of the mystic arts
victor von doom actually removes man's
messed up he removes his hands
and replaces them with robotic hands
basically allowing steven strange to go
forward
able to engage in the kind of surgery
that he's used to with better precision
than he was able to
able to do with uh with his normal hands
that's messed up i'm just gonna throw it
out there that's that's kind of messed
up
it's funny like it's funny to me i don't
know why
but that's that's kind of messed up but
the fact remains here
that because the ancient one realizes
that
doctor doom didn't help steven strange
when he could have
the ancient one comes to the conclusion
that doom is not the protege he was
looking for and so the idea of the
ancient
one is to basically shoot doctor doom
out of there as fast as possible
to more or less help him rescue his
mother's soul and then get him away
from the temple as fast as he can and so
what happens
is the ancient one
i love this the ancient one presents uh
doctor doom
with the eye of agamotto and the cloak
of levitation but
but when he meets him when doctor doom
has his ironclad suit on the ancient one
just kind of freaks out he's totally
surprised by what he sees because it's
crazy and and it is
this is why i love dr doom you know he's
like it is i
like it is uh i i don't know why that's
funny to me but it is
but the fact remains that dr doom and
the ancient one travel to the nether
realm
in order to confront mephisto now
because of the fact that dr doom has
the abilities of the sorcerer supreme uh
he's wildly powerful
but he's not as powerful as mephisto
something to keep in mind here is that
in marvel comics mephisto is for all
intents and purposes
a cosmic entity i mean he's an elder god
but he's largely considered to be a
cosmic entity because he's so powerful
he literally uses the energies of the
souls
that belong to people that he's tricked
to power himself and the reason for this
is that it keeps him at his
at his absolute peak in terms of his
abilities when he's in the nether realm
now when he leaves the nether realm he
becomes weaker the longer he stays away
but the fact remains here
that when dr doom arrives alongside the
ancient one
he immediately sees that his mother is
still being held captive and races off
to help her and because of this
mephisto sees the two of them as being
stronger together than they are apart
and as a result of their separation he
turns the sights to the ancient one now
what
follows is really just a mishmash of
insanity of the highest level
um this is this is probably some of the
craziest writing that i've ever seen in
my life and i have no idea where dan
sloth went with this
so what happens here is the ancient one
initially is able to take on the forces
of
mephisto but the issue is that mephisto
because of his extreme power
is able to overcome the ancient one and
actually kills him
and because of this the demon lord
dormammu
sees this as a chance to begin his
invasion of earth due to the fact that
dormammu was always held at bay
by the power of the ancient one now when
it comes to dormammu something to bear
in mind here
is that stephen strange himself has
admitted that if dormammu were to rise
to full power and invade the planet
earth
there'd probably be nothing anybody
could do to stop him just because
dormammu is so
wildly powerful um i feel like he's a
character we need to have a discussion
on at some point
closer to the release of doctor strange
just because i really hope the movie has
a trait has a
a nod to him or a tease to him because
uh dormammu is
he is a villain of the highest order i
mean he's
he's well he's he's wildly powerful he's
well beyond galactus
some of the cosmic entities it's insane
how powerful he is but the fact remains
that the ancient
one after having been killed so to speak
by mephisto
reemerges as i guess in his spirit form
and because of because he's in a spirit
form he's his powers at his peak but he
can't really interact directly with
mephisto instead he basically uses his
power to move on to the afterlife while
simultaneously rescuing the soul
of dr doom's mother thereby allowing dr
doom himself to step into the realm of
being the ancient one and so because of
this
he basically leaves mephisto behind in
the nether realm travels back to the
planet earth only to find
that dormammu has begun the process of
invading the planet earth and so what
happens
is doctor doom travels god in heaven
dance slot
doctor doom travels to meet the
fantastic four now again this
is this all kind of coincides right with
the current timeline of doctor doom in
marvel comics during this point in his
publication history anyway it's just
things are happening differently
and so instead of encountering the
fantastic four
after he became dr doom and took over
latviria instead he's re-encountering
the fantastic four after having become
the sorcerer supreme in addition to this
danson actually does a pretty good job
maintaining the
uh the essence of who the fantastic four
are in the sense that of course dr doom
shows up and says that he could just
wipe them all out if he wanted to
um but the issue is he needs read
richard's help because reed richards is
the second smartest person
according to doctor doom and the idea is
that he needs an artifact
of this that's long since been lost in
order to successfully
defeat uh dormammu so what he does is he
teleports the fantastic four
into the past and has them disguised as
pirates
and the idea is to have the fantastic
four board a ship
that currently houses the obsidian stone
of merlin
which can be used to defeat dormammu
that is the idea that danslock came up
with and people wonder why spider-man is
being written so bad at the moment but
the fact remains here
that dr doom and the fantastic four are
successfully able to work together in
the sense of the fantastic four
are able to grasp the uh the obsidian
stone which is specially attuned for
magical properties
which can which of course you know dr
doom can in turn enhance
and then take on the forces of dormammu
which he's successfully able to do and
the result of this is that dormammu is
effectively
cast back into the dark dimension and
earth is freed of his control the
problem with this
is that you know dr doom seems to
succumb to the power of the obsidian
stone
in the sense that it drains the souls of
its wielder and the result of this is
that dr doom seems to be dead or on the
verge of dying now
while he is taken over to stephen
strange for the purpose of
strange using his uh his his surgical
skills in order to try to save the life
of victor von doom it doesn't seem as if
it's possible and it seems as if victor
von doom is dying
but what happens is doom says that he
had planned for this and the reason why
was that when he first encountered
steven strange
he sensed that strange had the potential
for incredible magical abilities and so
what he did is he created a safeguard he
created a machine
that would allow him to continue his
legacy and what he does
is he basically has the mind of steven
strange removed or at least has his
memories removed and overridden
with the memories of victor von doom
basically allowing doom to switch bodies
between who he was
and the body of steven strange i don't
know if that makes any sense to you guys
um i'll be honest man this story's
batshit crazy
[Laughter]
this story is insane uh this is wow
uh i mean it's fun
you know it's fun it's a fun you know
it's a story i enjoyed
uh it is just it's it's a what-if story
we'll leave it at that anyway guys if
you guys are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button
and uh you know make sure you guys
become part of the rob core make sure
you guys drop a like if you enjoyed this
video and uh leave a comment down below
and let me know what you think um
was dan slott on something when he wrote
this story but yeah so
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end good god and i will
catch you all later
peace all right there is a story
there's a story where uh deadpool
becomes venom now this story is
this story is written by rick remender
and it is a descent into absolute
madness uh
partly because of the fact that on his
mask deadpool is wearing a mustache i
don't know how that works
but apparently it does now uh this story
also picks up in 1985. now
the the kicker about all this is that
this treats uh secret wars 2
as if it never really ended right i mean
when when jim shooter wrote secret wars
1 and it was just this mysterious being
called the beyonder that took all the
villains and all the heroes and it put
them on battle world and it made them
fight each other you know when this
story first popped up in 1984 it was all
the rage was like yeah this is crazy
this is awesome you know
it was meant to be a one-off but because
of his popularity marvel launched secret
wars number two which basically gave
expansion on the beyond or the beyonder
you know was curious about humanity
showed up on earth and looked like john
travolta from saturday night fever so
what ended up happening
is in this story the beyonder never left
the beyonder was never defeated by the
molecule man owen reese instead the
beyonder was
the beyond was messing around with
people now deadpool is contracted
by galactus and the reason why he's
contracted by galactus
is because the beyonder
merged modok with the butt of galactus
i don't know else how i don't know how
else to say that like i don't know how
else to
to to say that to you guys
uh but the idea here is that galactus
basically contracts uh
or at least he gives deadpool the uh the
reckoning sponge of fire and says your
job is to go after the beyonder and
basically use the retcon expungifier to
annihilate him from existence now of
course we know the expunge of fire is
basically like a stand-in for the
ultimate nullifier right like the
ultimate nullifier can obliterate things
from existence well the retcon
expungifier removes things from
continuity
so it's it basically it treats the
beyonder like he never existed is
essentially what happens the problem
with this
is that when deadpool finds the beyonder
he's just totally enamored by
he's totally enamored by his jerry curls
apparently his jerry curls are
absolutely incredible
and because of that deadpool can't let
it go not only that for some reason or
another
deadpool has jerry curl now which is
which is weird but the funny thing about
this too is uh
apparently the beyonder took billy ocean
and made him his limo driver now for
those of you guys who don't know billy
ocean was a guy who did the the
caribbean
the caribbean queen song you know now
we're sharing the same dream you know
like
he's the one that did that song and uh
apparently the
beyonder loved it so much that he made
billy ocean his
driver but there's also another reason
why he brought in billy ocean the reason
for this is keep in mind this basically
treats the events of secret wars like
they actually happen in the sense that
peter parker eventually came across the
venom symbiote not knowing what it was
thinking it was a suit it bonded to
peter parker and he came back to earth
with his new costume
of course being a superhero he
immediately attacks the beyonder and of
course is like look you know you
made me who i am he basically made me
this venom character but then we
realized the other reason why
billy ocean is here is that in addition
to being one of the most famous singers
of all times
uh he is he's he's he's very good at
killing people
and what he basically what he basically
does he is this is
god recommender man quick reminder
writes this line where he says hey
spider-man
get into my dreams and out of my car now
this is basically a flip on the phrase
on the song that billy ocean did where
he's like you know get out of my dreams
and into my bed like that's basically
that's the song they're playing on god i
love this dude i love this story the
crazy thing about this though with
regards to venom becoming uh
i'm sorry deadpool becoming venom uh
because of the fact that peter parker's
basically blasted with the
you know this weapon whatever it is that
billy ocean's using that the singer
billy ocean's using uh the venom
symbiotes cast off of peter parker and
in response it merges itself
to deadpool now at this point we
basically pick up like we literally just
jump forward to 1993 and the beyonder
has been living like this wild life this
ridiculously fun life but but the
novelties wore off
not only that and man dude rick
remembers cold-blooded this one
not only that uh tony stark is a
full-blown
alcoholic like the the his whole
alcoholism has gotten the best of him
and there is god rick remember there is
this uh
really messed up line where deadpool's
like what happened to the reconyx sponge
of fire
you know whatever happened to that
because i still have to kill the
beyonder and tony stark says we pawned
it we pawned it with the
with the rest of my iron man suit and
then he says he kept the glove
he's still iron man he's still in
control this is uh this is
this is kind of offensive to be honest
like i've known alcoholics is kind of
offensive to alcoholics but it's also
tony stark and it's a deadpool comic
so it's i guess take it for what it's
worth but what ends up happening here is
deadpool basically says okay fine you
know if we don't have the reconyx sponge
of fire then i'm basically going to be a
good guy and so what he does is he
basically sells
he sells tony stark to advanced idea
mechanics he literally
sells tony stark and i guess they're
going to take his brain are they going
to do whatever
they do i don't think we ever find out
but from here he basically goes on this
trip to try to become a superhero by
joining different groups of course he
goes to the fantastic four and read
richard says we do not hire curly haired
people which of course is one of the
most severe instances of discrimination
that i've ever seen uh he goes to the
avengers mansion and jarvis chases him
off with a broom
and then he goes he goes to the
defenders god the defenders suck he goes
to the defenders and the defenders are
desperate they're like you running the
doorbell of the defenders we're hiring
please and he's like
nope he doesn't even want to work with
the defenders no one likes a defender so
that's that's messed up now that's old
school defenders i'm pretty sure the new
marvel now 2.0 defenders will be pretty
amazing but in the end
like the you know deadpool looks around
and basically says the problem the
reason why he's not able to find gainful
employment
is because of the fact that the venom
symbiote exists in the form of jerry
curl on his head now this is
uh this is ridiculous this is when rick
remember well if the comic hadn't gone
off the rails before it goes off the
rails now
like this is when rick reminder really
uh just kind of loses it and the reason
why
is because you know it seems like the
deadpool does not have the venom
symbiont but he still has the powers of
spider-man i don't know how
i don't know how that works but it does
and so what he says is okay look you
know if no one's gonna take me on as a
superhero then i'm gonna be my own
superhero and he essentially just goes
around killing people like that's what
he does he just kills criminals
everywhere that he finds them not only
that we find out that the beyonder has
basically
reinvigorated the battleworld concept in
the sense that instead of like
traditional superheroes you know
fighting against crime
instead they're all basically just
fighting against each other in this
giant battle right now now when deadpool
gets there rick remender starts making
making fun of comic book fans he makes
fun of you he makes fun of me like he
makes fun of comic book fans there's
this guy
i guess he's super something i don't
know the century or something like that
but there's this guy that appears
to uh to deadpool and basically says you
look ridiculous in that costume that guy
over there
is wearing an american flag and he's got
an american flag discus
that guy is an iconic hero and then the
response of deadpool
is like hey look man i mean that doesn't
really matter i mean the suit doesn't
really matter
you know i mean you have like that guy
over there who's basically moon knight
you know he's just as good as captain
america or something along those lines
but then like this weird superhero just
like freaks out this is when rick mender
starts making fun
of fans because he's like you do not
take superheroes on the street and put
them
on teams with big superheroes street
superheroes stay in their place
big team superheroes stay in their place
you can't allow things to mix because if
you allow things to mix then it makes it
different and things that are different
are weird and i don't understand it and
i get confused and i don't like it and
it's it's
it's him making fun of comic book fans
basically saying comic book fans don't
like change
like comic book fans are scared of
change because it puts them in a
position where they're not comfortable
as a comic book fan i don't consider
that to be the case but i think it's
also pretty funny like
it's pretty hilarious but the fact
remains here that we basically pick up
you know we pick up with jerry springer
this comic is insane
we pick up with jerry springer and
apparently we have deadpool we have some
chick with the venom symbiote hair now
with the jerry curl and then we have the
beyonder
and they're here because of the fact
that
this girl who's calling herself the
carnage curl
is with the beyonder and deadpool's
upset about it deadpool's angry just
because of the fact that this girl
caused him so much hassle the reason why
was because deadpool's goal
was to invite the beyonder over to his
house for
grand gala and the goal was to just
basically kill the beyonder the issue
with this
is that the beyonder brought his
ex-girlfriend brought deadpool's
ex-girlfriend with him and his
ex-girlfriend apparently carnage crow
was just like this crazy chick
that like burned his house down that
like dropped a deuce in his home
i mean it was it was it was really
messed up but
uh in the end like she basically says
look i'm with the beyonder now
you have to show me some respect and
when deadpool's like why
she says because i'm pregnant now the
reason why this is ridiculous is because
if you guys ever watched jerry springer
back in the day
it was like the big huge drop it was
like man like you know this guy's been
cheating on me or something like that or
this girl's been cheating on me or it's
just like some ridiculous situation
and then like the mic drop moment is
like i'm pregnant
and it's just it's it's like oh my god
well then we find out
that apparently the beyonder is not the
father of this child
the father of this child is galactus
the plot thickens galactus fathered like
he basically slept with beyonder's
girlfriend
in order to get his revenge on the
beyonder merging modoc with his butt and
so because of this the two of them just
get into a massive fight and the earth
is destroyed now from here
rick remembers like whatever hashtag
logic we end up picking up with deadpool
having saved the world
and the reason why is because in the
fight between galactus and the beyonder
deadpool was just like all right you
guys are
losing your minds you guys are way too
powerful to be fighting like this you're
gonna you're gonna wipe everything out
of existence he used the retcon
expungifier to obliterate them from
continuity
and so the world celebrated deadpool
they were like yeah deadpool saved the
world deadpool is amazing
well the problem with this is that in
the mind of deadpool he's been seeking
admiration this entire time he's been
seeking people
to look at him and believe that he is
the best he's
the best superhero the greatest of all
the superheroes the issue with this is
that you still have superheroes around
there and so deadpool's not getting
everyone's adoration instead you know
they're they're celebrating thor they're
celebrating captain america so on and so
forth and so what deadpool decides to do
is kill thor it's the most logical thing
apparently for deadpool to do and so he
go so when thor is using the bathroom
deadpool runs up on him he grabs his
hammer he kills thor he basically
becomes
deadpool venom thor and then kills all
the superheroes except for the women
that he considers to be attractive so
that they can admire how attractive
attractive he is and so on the problem
with this is that he's basically just
become a dick like that's what he is
he's basically like yes i'm the greatest
person in the world you all should
worship me but it's funny because he's
having this conversation with doc
sampson and doc sampson's like no
usually when it comes to something like
this where people say that nobody
respects them or they're causing drama
or something like that they usually do
things like causing drama because it
makes them feel like they're achieving
something when they're not
but he also says that the reason why
people didn't like you before
was because you were a dick i mean you
could say sure like they just didn't
respect you because you were a small
time superhero or you weren't
really more of an anti-hero more than
anything else but it was really just
because you were a jerk and no one liked
you
and so in response deadpool rips off the
head of doc sampson
goes and grabs the reckonic spongifier
and like
retcons the story out of continuity
that's basically that's how rick
remender ends this this story
essentially doesn't exist
in marvel comics seems to be the case
this story is insane
but i love it i love the story where
deadpool becomes venom because it's so
ridiculous
because it's so insane and i think that
every once in a while we have to read
crazy insane comics
because they help to keep us grounded
it's like it's like sci-fi movies right
like sometimes you just gotta sit down
and you gotta watch frankenfish not
because frankenfish is a good movie
not because it's anywhere close to what
anybody could even consider to be
anything remotely near a good movie
but because of the fact that you you
just need things like that
it's like that with everything right i
mean you gotta play games like call of
duty so you can play the bad and you can
appreciate the good you play call of
duty like man i really like battlefield
or if you hate battlefield and you play
call of duty you say i play battlefield
so i can appreciate call of duty
whatever the case may be like you got to
have everything in balance
you know and i love the way this whole
thing this whole thing comes out but the
fact remains if you guys are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like i'm sure there's
going to be a few people who take
themselves too seriously you're like oh
you were laughing in the video and i
don't like it but uh in any of it guys
we're going to bring this to an end and
i will catch you all later peace
okay so with monday being our i guess
our weekly hulk video now i mean i
didn't really intend for it to be this
way but it's kind of turned out that way
we're gonna be talking about the
incredible hulk's wife conquering earth
and it's actually kind of a cool story
this all goes back to the whole planet
hulk thing and that's one of the funny
things
that we did we really didn't do a whole
lot of like what-if stories when it came
to like planet hulk world war hulk
different things like that
by and large the most popular what if
story we did for plan for uh world war
hulk rather
was the incredible whole killing all the
superheroes and then becoming galactus
as herald but that was really about it i
mean we really didn't do a whole lot of
what ifs
what this does is it gives us an
alternate take on the original planet
hulk event now for those of you guys who
are new
to you know the incredible hulk in
general you'll find a playlist
with some 30 or 40 videos about the
incredible hulk that just runs through
all of his best stories it's like this
great big you know five or six year long
story written by a guy named greg pack
that ran
from the original planet hulka van all
the way up through world war hulk the
you know after shocks or aftermath
rather and then going up to you know a
couple of ancillary stories here and
there leading into secret wars and then
going into all new all different marvel
this one i'm gonna go ahead and throw in
there probably after
planet hulk to be honest just because
it's a what if story but planet hulk
centered on the idea that the incredible
hulk was just too
unpredictable and too violent for the
earth's superheroes and the result was
that there was a group called the
illuminati
and the illuminati were basically this
kind of inner circle
of uh reed richards professor xavier it
was actually captain america at one
point before his mind was wiped uh dr
strange
and they basically i guess you know tony
stark and they basically all just kind
of banded together
for the purpose of keeping the earth
protected from you know external and
internal threats what they ended up
doing is they basically
shot the incredible hulk into space and
the goal was to send him to a peaceful
planet where he could basically live out
his days without having to worry about
threats or anything along those lines
and without being a threat to earth the
problem was he ended up on this planet
called sikar which resulted in him
basically being turned into a slave and
then becoming a gladiator and then all
that kind of good stuff
at the end of that planet hulk story he
had basically found love with a woman
named kyra
and they actually ended up you know
starting a family of sorts or at least
she ended up getting pregnant and
in the midst of you know rebuilding this
empire after the incredible hulk had
conquered the existing king
the illuminati ship had basically
exploded it had detonated due to its
nuclear core
being tampered with and things going
awry which ultimately resulted in the
incredible hulk's wife kiera
basically being killed this led into
world war hulk when the incredible hulk
showed up back to earth and crushed
everybody
it was a really cool story what this
does is it gives us an alternate take it
pretty much runs over everything that we
just talked about a second ago the
difference here is that in the moment
when this
ship began to go awry and began to
detonate the incredible hulk grabbed
kyra
and threw her out of the blast zone and
ended up being killed himself in the
process now there
are a couple of things that marvel does
here that we just kind of have to take
with a grain of salt the incredible hulk
being killed in a nuclear explosion for
example under normal circumstances the
incredible hulk would never be killed in
a nuclear blast he's too durable he's
too powerful he's too strong
that would never happen he'd probably be
injured but he would never be
killed in a nuclear explosion he'd
withstand it and then he would just kind
of keep on keeping on in fact that's
where we got maestro hulk from when the
world
you know basically collapsed into
nuclear war and maestro hulk
emerged with bruce banner kind of being
driven insane by all this
radiation and then you know kind of
conquering what was left of humanity and
then just crowning himself king
the other half of this is that with kyra
effectively surviving she basically
bonds herself with the entirety of the
old power now the old power was this
concept created by greg pack
for the purpose of just offering an
explanation as to how it was
nick heyer was able to do the things she
was as well as setting the groundwork
for the introduction of the incredible
hulk son
scar now we talked about the old power
in our videos on on greg pack's whole
run planet hulk world war hulk all that
kind of good stuff but the old power is
basically
this energy of sorts that was sort of
either created or tapped into
by a group of individuals and was
designed to basically counter
the power cosmic of galactus the problem
with this was that only certain people
could actually
access it individuals who were
considered to be the old strong and the
result was that when they did it it
basically
amplified whatever existing power they
had and then those who hadn't
manipulated or knew how to manipulate it
effectively could actually make
themselves almost
on par with galactus in terms of their
abilities that's what we saw with
the incredible hulk's second son hiro
kala the the things that he was able to
do
the kind of stunts he was able to pull
off with regards to this particular
story
kaira actually absorbs the entirety of
the old power from within the planet of
sakhar itself
and then in turn intends to travel back
to earth now one thing to keep in mind
she's not on par
with galactus and this particular level
of strength but she's well beyond all
the other earth's superheroes and the
way this plays out
is that she basically arrives or at
least the first place she conquers
is the moon now again those of you guys
who saw our videos on world war hulk or
who are watching comicstorians videos on
world war hook this follows almost
directly in line with the events as they
unfolded there in terms of the steps
that were taken there's a few
differences here the first
is that the incredible hulk did arrive
on the moon the reason why was because
of the fact that the inhumans had long
since
resided on the moon they had basically
left earth during the events of inhumans
vol
2 i think it was and they'd basically
been on the moon ever since but the idea
here
was that the incredible hulk had stopped
at the moon first because black bolt the
king of the inhumans was one of the
illuminati one of the people who
banished him and the result was that
you know the incredible hulk basically
conquered black bolt with this
we don't see that happen we don't see
that take place another difference here
is the sentry robber reynolds in the
original world war hulk story the sentry
and uh and the incredible hulk just
basically
beat the crap out of one another and it
was actually really really cool to see
the sentry was like this one guy who
could stand against the incredible hulk
really the only one who was able to pull
it off but what ends up happening here
is that because of the fact that kyra
basically attacks the inhumans and in
doing so just
blows off a massive chunk of the moon it
catches the attention of the earth's
superheroes before she ever arrives now
of course he ends up tapping into the
satellites that orbit the earth and then
broadcast a message telling the
illuminati that they're all going to die
that the earth's superheroes are all
going to be killed because they're the
reason why the incredible hulk was
banished in the first place but in their
attempt to try to get to her before she
arrives to new york we end up finding
out that she has black bolt in tow
now this is one of the other things that
kind of requires us to
not really stress the limits of
credulity but to sort of you know modify
how we normally see black bull because
black bull's powers have waxed and waned
over the years for those of you guys who
don't know
black bolt has you know super strength
speed so on and so forth but his most
formidable power is a quasi-sonic scream
and what it means is that if he tries to
talk he'll destroy whatever's in his
path now there's been stories where he's
been power
powerful enough to shatter planets
there's been stories like house of
m with just a whisper he was almost
infinitely more powerful than he was in
the mainline marvel universe and this
particular story it seems like it's
really hitting back to the power that he
had during house of m
and the reason we know that is because
of the fact that as soon as kaira grabs
him she immediately tells him to
basically speak now of course under
normal circumstances black bolt would
never do this but remember back when the
incredible hulk was on sakar
one of the reasons why he was forced
into servitude as a gladiator is because
he had been bonded with an obedience
disc and while the obedience disc didn't
modify his mind what it did do is it
sent a series of electric currents
through whoever the disc was bonded to
until they did what they were told it
was just basically a way to force
control and the result is that when
kaira activates this obedience disc
black bolt simply says
no and then obliterates the sentry and
doctor strange now
doctor strange we could easily see him
being destroyed especially if he doesn't
have time to cast a spell
to protect him from from black bolts
quasi-sonic screen the sentry is a
little more questionable here it's one
of those things where it's kind of like
i don't really know if blackboard would
be able to destroy the century but it's
still kind of a cool thing it's still
kind of a cool little bit of a story
here but following this
this is where things begin to differ
because remember when the incredible
hulk showed up in new york due to the
events of world war hulk it was really
one of those just capture everybody
capture the members of the illuminati
and then we're going to force them to
fight in the gladiatorial games kyra
does not have the same restraint as the
incredible hulk and this makes sense
because remember the incredible hulk
fought alongside almost all these
superheroes at some point or another
over the course of his life as a hero
he's fought alongside the avengers he's
fought alongside the x-men he's fought
alongside the fantastic four he's also
fought against them as well but whether
they were enemies or whether they were
friends there's a kind of camaraderie
that existed between all of them with
this particular story
kaira does not have that camaraderie in
her mind they're bad guys
they're the reason why her husband's
dead and they're all going to die and
that's exactly what she does she
literally takes to almost all of your
superheroes iron man is killed
reed richards of the fantastic four is
killed all these guys are basically
taken out now remember with her having
the old power she's able to manipulate
the very forces of the earth itself
in addition to amplifying her own power
so not only are the earth superheroes
fighting against kyra they're also
fighting against the planet that they
live on now the way that things begin to
shift is in truth it would have been
very
easy for her to obliterate the entirety
of the earth's superheroes for the most
part
because the power she possesses is well
beyond anything they have
but in this moment she's basically told
that would be foolish it would be stupid
to kill the entirety of the earth's
superheroes because
then what are you going to rule are you
going to rule a sender you're going to
rule a giant uninhabited planet there's
not going to be anything here for you to
have any possession of and so the result
is that she actually ends up backing off
and we jump forward about 21 years later
only for us to find out that she had
basically
bonded the entirety of the earth
superhero community with obedience discs
you know and these include people like
colossus she-hulk so on and so forth but
the other thing that we're also
sort of given here is this idea that the
whole of humanity have been bonded with
these obedience discs now we don't know
for sure we're not told that
explicitly but that seems to be the case
just because of the fact that there are
people here who do not have powers that
have been bonded with obedience discs
now the other half of this is we also
have to imagine
that in this conflict various
superheroes have probably been killed i
mean the city of new york is in the
process of being rebuilt but we also
find out that this massive monument
is being constructed now of course this
comes directly from scar himself now
remember in the incredible hulk line of
stories in the mainline marvel comics
scar had basically survived this nuclear
explosion after he was released by his
mother and then preserved
using the uh the power of the old strong
in order to keep him in case in this
kind of molten cocoon and the result was
that he emerged he eventually made his
escape from zakar
and then showed up on earth to battle
his father whom he considered to be
someone that just kind of abandoned him
or left him behind
in this story that's not the case cairo
was of course pregnant with him but
presumably gave birth on earth to him
and then in turn raced him in her own
image but of course we end up finding
out this massive structure that's being
built is designed explicitly to
basically pay homage to the incredible
hulk not only that with his hand being
outstretched we end up finding out that
this is basically kaira's testament to
him
in the sense that she leaves the
entirety of earth in control of her
son's scar
and then just sort of joins the statue
of bruce banner effectively giving up
her power and sacrificing her life in
the process so again it's kind of a
weird situation it's a little strange in
terms of how this unfolds but it's also
sort of cool because this shows us the
lengths that the incredible hulk's wife
would go to
in order to basically avenge her
husband's death and with the power that
she possessed it was enough to
effectively
conquer the entirety of the earth take
over all these different superheroes and
supervillains kill those that rebelled
and then make the place her own so again
it's a pretty cool story and it's pretty
interesting in terms of how it unfolds
but yeah i thought it'd be kind of fun
to just sort of throw this what if story
out there and just say hey here's a
really cool story with the incredible
hulk
we've covered mostly origin videos so
far we'll probably end up doing uh hulk
2099 at some point
but the idea is just kind of run through
these different little incredible hulk
things that a lot of people have been
asking for
since we originally did planet hulk
world war hulk and all that kind of
stuff but if you guys are new here to
comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robcor if you enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah i mean not too bad for
you know like a 13-page story it's not
that long
it's actually from uh planet hulk what
if which has like three or four
different stories all combined into one
there's one story where it's like what
if bruce banner had landed on sakhar
instead of the incredible hulk what if
the incredible whole kid landed on the
planet that he was supposed to where it
was peaceful it's kind of cool because
he eventually becomes a god but
uh nonetheless you know it's one of
these interesting concepts but anyway
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and i will catch you all
later
peace so for this week's what if story i
figured we do the story of what if
the century killed the marvel universe
now this actually comes out
as a what if story as a counterpart to
siege which is actually issue number 200
it's actually pretty cool
but for those of you guys who don't know
i've done a video on siege which you'll
find down in the description
but the basis of this was really like
the conclusion of everything that had
come after civil war i mean we had the
superhuman registration act we had
secret
invasion we had dark rain where norman
osborne had replaced tony stark as
director of shield and norman osborne
had looked to basically take over the
world the idea of siege brought all
these things to an end so it saw the
disbanding of the superhuman
registration act it saw the defeat of
norman osborne
it saw the death of robert reynolds in
the original story the death of the
century
this what if story takes a different
approach so during dark rain
norman osborne had basically replaced
the avengers with
villains because for a lot of people out
there they knew about the identity of
some of the heroes but they didn't know
all of them and so for example hawkeye
was basically replaced with bullseye uh
norman osborne himself took over the
role of iron man operating under the
role of or under the name of iron
patriot with the iron man armor
um we had a multitude of heroes who were
essentially just replaced with villains
and then osborne used them as a way to
effectively solidify his reign now we
also had groups like the x-men which
were basically outliers in the sense
that norman osborn's control at the time
was really isolated to the continental
united states and so for the x-men they
effectively
left the continental united states they
formed their own society in a place
called utopia off the coast of san
francisco and they operated outside of
norman osborn's control
so because of this they were able to
basically try to thwart his efforts as
best they could but there really wasn't
a whole lot that they could do because
remember
this is a point in the history of the
x-men where the mutant population
has been reduced by 98 so there's only a
very small portion of them left
who can effectively fight against
osborne and so during the original
siege event asgard as it existed in
oklahoma was really like the last
bastion
of norman osborne solidifying his rule
and then
taking the steps to essentially take
over the government and make himself
dictator
and so because of this he had basically
brought along a lot of his a lot of his
his ilk his cabal
and led a campaign to take over asgard
now the kicker to this was that you
still had
thor you still had a lot of heroes who
were there you had uh loki who was kind
of the hidden hand behind it all but the
idea here
was that osborne had gone against the
forces of asgard and he gone against you
know the avengers under captain america
when they had realized what was going on
and they basically rallied to the call
and so uh norman osborne was essentially
defeated here in this story we take a
different approach
in the original siege event or i guess
in the events of dark rain really the
events that led up to siege
norman osborne had essentially had uh
the century's wife lindy
killed by bullseye and then he had used
the emotional state of robert reynolds
to manipulate him
into following the ideologies of norman
osborne hence having one of the most
powerful beings in existence on his side
with this particular story instead of
fighting ares the god of war
on the battlefield during the siege of
asgard instead
robert reynolds had fought him several
days beforehand and what this meant was
that instead of like the original siege
on asgard story where robert reynolds
was basically
exhausted after fighting uh fighting
ares in this story he's
fully energized he has he's lost
virtually none of his power and because
of this
he's quite literally a one-man army i
mean robert reynolds goes through he
kills luke cage by punching a hole in
him he kills
thor like he he cuts off the head of
captain america
and it was actually really really messed
up he was it was funny
it's not funny that's not
funny that captain america's head got
cut off that's
it is funny because like like scarlet or
not a scarf sweater um
spider woman jessica drew is like no
it's hilarious to me but the idea here
is that robert reynolds allowed for
norman osborne's villains
to effectively go through and start
killing off what was left to the
superheroes because you gotta keep in
mind captain america despite not having
any real superpowers per se
is like a moral rallying point for all
of the superheroes i mean they looked to
steve rogers as the one guy that was
solidified in brian michael bendis's age
of ultron
when everything had come crashing down
all the superheroes were waiting on
steve rogers to formulate a plan that's
literally what they were waiting on they
were waiting on him to get his act
together to figure out what to do next
they ultimately settled on traveling to
one of nick fury's bunkers when he was
still alive but the idea was you know
during age of ultron it was established
that captain america was the rallying
guy and it always been that way that
story just kind of solidified it as
being an
absolute truth but with him being killed
here the superheroes haven't really lost
their will to fight so much as they've
lost any real measure of organization
and so again we have the avengers coming
in much like we did before
we have iron man we have you know uh
wolverine you know we have the x-men
cyclops we have them coming in
of course the x-men again didn't play a
major role in the original events of
siege but they're showing up here but it
doesn't matter because they're
all being defeated by you know robert
reynolds and by these various heroes and
so
the way things begin to differentiate is
emma frost
effectively has to watch his cyclops
died but during this process
dr doom arrives dr doom steps in and
says hey we gotta get out of here like i
have magic that's basically hiding our
our existence here but it won't be long
before this magic wears off they realize
that we're here and then they kill us so
we've got to bail out because i have a
plan and so she ends up going with dr
doom and they arrive back at utopia now
again utopia is this area where the
x-men are basically operating out of but
there's only a handful of them left now
from those who had originally been
killed
and so you know when the when the
question is what's your plan you know
what what goal do you have here we're
suddenly met
by the arrival of loki and loki is the
one that says hey i have a plan i'm the
one that that has this idea on how we're
going to fix everything and so
at this point we really just kind of
have norman osborne in the background
solidifying his reign in the sense that
he informs carla and he informs mack
a couple of his henchmen to basically go
and kill the president of the united
states thereby allowing norman osborn to
solidify himself as absolute ruler of
the world
we also have you know bullseye trying to
be dealt with by some of these other
heroes as well but it's really just this
attempt by them to uh
to eliminate as many of northern
osborne's heroes as they can
before they end up getting into robert
reynolds now following this
robert reynolds is actually brought to
them by loki and this was the plan
of loki himself his plan was to
basically go to reynolds and to say hey
bullseye was the one that killed your
wife
norman osborne was the one who
instructed him to do it now initially he
doesn't believe them but
emma frost says hey you know let me use
my powers let me go into your mind
and i'll show you what it is that had
happened and when he sees what took
place
he immediately kills her and the reason
why he does this is because robert
reynolds
transforms into the void now this is a
great time to have that conversation
because
i've seen so many people ask that i saw
the in the siege comments or the siege
video people were asking in the comments
section is the void more powerful than
robert reynolds
yes robert reynolds it's really kind of
like his powers are sort of a mishmash
there are some that say that he has the
ability to warp reality and that's kind
of been confirmed to a degree
in marvel comics there are some that say
he's just super powerful and his power
is whatever the writers need him to do
at any one particular point in time like
that is just what his power is
his he has he has powers of convenience
but the idea here is that robert
reynolds always has like a moral compass
he always keeps the void in check the
void
is all the anger and all the hate of
robert reynolds
manifested into a physical being and
it's unbridled power
i mean just unbridled untapped uh
uncontrollable power
in the most extreme and so it's
literally just
a force of nature is the best way to
describe the void it is
and it's an insane reckoning and we see
this because the void literally
kills everyone it kills doctor doom now
the death of dr doom which doctor doom
always seems to die in stories like this
but the death of doctor doom is so cool
because you know
the the void says hey look if you want a
bag you can beg and dr doom says nope i
don't beg
and so void says okay fine and just
kills him off no questions no nothing
kills off one of the most powerful
mystics
one of the most powerful beings in
existence after that he turns his
attention to norman osborn and kills
norman osborn and so from here it's
basically you know humanity
launching its weapons it's you know it's
weapons of war it's bombs and so on
against the center against
the void with no effort whatsoever
nothing happening
out of this and after this the void
basically begins going through and
killing all those heroes that just
didn't show up at the siege on asgard it
kills all these beings that just simply
didn't make it to that event for
whatever reason and so what we learn is
that this entire series of events is
actually being watched by
a uh by a member of the watcher named
atau now this is actually a deviation
from the status quo in marvel comics all
the what if stories are basically told
to us
from uwatu the watcher and the reason
why was established again in the
original sin story when he walked to the
watcher had access to see
all the other universes that exist out
there and so it was like we were
watching it through the eyes of the
watcher as he was looking at a viewing
screen
but what happens is this is actually
another guy named uh named tao who's you
know relaying these events to a watching
the watcher and the implication here
is that not only does the void go
through and
wipe out all life on earth and destroy
the earth itself it also seems
like the void is going to eventually
destroy the moon and then make its way
through the entirety of the universe
killing everything off now the question
is could the boy do that
yes the void could easily go through and
kill the cosmic entities kill the
celestials kill galactus because
remember the void's power is
limitless there's no there's nothing the
void can't do and so any foe
that goes against the void the void will
have enough power to kill that foe every
single time
across the board without fail this is
why this the character of the century is
uh
so derisive in marvel comics and this is
you know because it's he's really just
kind of like a trump card
like century enters the fray and then
whatever side he's on wins but it's also
the other reason why the century
and the comics had always tried to keep
the void at bay because if the void
would
were to go unleashed like it did here uh
then it would just lead to the
destruction of everything this is really
just showing us what happens when the
void when the sentry basically lets his
guard down and allows the void
to completely take over and you know
what what the ramifications would be for
a situation like that it's just the void
wiping out all things in existence but
if you guys are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
drop a like and leave a comment down
below
let me know what you guys think about
the century robert reynolds let me know
how you guys feel about him because i
know
he's really popular but really hardcore
comic book fans hate him but people who
are casual fans
think he's interesting so i'm kind of
curious to see what side of the field
you guys uh take on this
i like him i think he's a cool character
i think that he was kind of misused
in the new avengers run when he was
folded over i think his best stories
came out of marvel nights but
you know i think that uh he's still a
pretty reasonable character still decent
i mean he's dead now
for those of you guys who don't know by
the way i want to go ahead and bring
this up too for those of you guys who
don't know the century dying in siege
was
the last time he officially appeared in
marvel comics he was kind of resurrected
as one of the four horsemen i think is
part of the apocalypse twins but that
wasn't really like this century as we
knew him the century as we knew him
is essentially gone um the old school
century appeared
in the uh contest of champions i think
but that doesn't count
like the the century as we know him is
is gone he's never been seen or heard
from again he may come back
but i don't think he will i think the
centuries is kind of gone he was a
difficult character to work with anyway
it was difficult to write stories for
him because he suffered from the
superman complex but the fact remains
you know that we may or may not see him
at some future point in time but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an
end and i will catch you all later
so as we continue our discussion
surrounding you know wolverine related
content in response to the trailer
for logan having been released what i
want to do here is i want to talk about
how
i want to talk about how wolverine
killed all the super villains now this
is this actually comes to us as issue
111
of the what if line of stories now for
those of you guys who know about what if
bear with me for a second while i went
over this for those who don't if you're
coming from dc comics the what if line
of publications are similar to
what you call else worlds the difference
here is that else worlds are just
stories that are out there they don't
usually tie into the existing continuity
the what if stories in marvel comics
do so it's like what if you know
wolverine had killed the incredible
hulk when the two of them first met when
wolverine first appeared in marvel
comics it was in a battle with the
incredible hulk the what if story is
based on
what if wolverine had killed the
incredible hulk in that battle then how
would the conflict turn out or how would
the world turn out
there's stories like what if an aunt may
had died instead of uncle ben
there are some really cool stories like
that but they always have their roots in
the main continuity for those of you
guys who are not coming from dc comics
that are just you know kind of curious
about marvel in and of itself the same
idea still applies that marvel has one
straight universe which is called the
earth 616 continuity and all the what if
stories are just alternate realities
that branch off of that now
this particular story actually has its
roots in wolverine
becoming a horseman of apocalypse now
the way this worked was that
in the mid 1990s uh comic books had just
been struggling in general and so the
goal was to try to reinvigorate them and
keep them interesting
but at the same time wolverine had lost
his adamantium in a battle with magneto
during the events of fatal attractions
which i'll actually have a video on
but because of this wolverine was
effectively sent off into the wild where
he became what's called
feral wolverine and his comics actually
lasted this way for quite some time the
issue with this was that it wasn't a
story that could be done forever
marvel eventually had to find a way to
bring him back to make him into the
wolverine that we always
knew and so what they did is they
basically initiated a story where the
villain apocalypse had kidnapped
wolverine
and sabertooth and basically said
whichever one of you
wins in a battle to the death will not
only
you know become my horseman war but will
also receive enhancements and so because
wolverine was still relatively feral at
this point because he was a far more
capable fighter than sabertooth was he
ultimately killed sabertooth and in
doing so
apocalypse restored his adamantium to
his bones
and made wolverine into the horseman war
now in that original story
wolverine's brainwashing was basically
worn off by a combination of jubilee and
the rest of the x-men who were able to
talk him down and bring him back
in this story that didn't happen instead
wolverine
remained the horseman war and so what we
do here is we initially pick up with a
group called the war watch and the war
watch basically just
functions to ensure that the world stays
safe and this is actually one of the
really cool concepts here because
in this you know in this future there is
no war between humans and mutants that
humans and mutants are basically living
in peace that xavier's dream of a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants has actually come to fruition in
addition to this
we also see that this uh what seems to
be this fledgling group of
young officers are brought in at the
behest of their sergeant and they're
basically told that there is a group
calling themselves the wolf pack who are
basically a gang that have been running
amok and they've been attacking stores
now
what this tells us is that in this
future that there is still violence
violence is very rare it doesn't happen
very often but when it does it's quickly
snuffed out and that these young people
are a combination of regular humans and
mutants who have come together under the
banner of the wolf pack and begun
engaging in violent acts and so what
ends up happening is the
war watch of course bands together these
police go out to the mall they attack
these young people they basically uh
they grab them they throw them uh or at
least they seem to subdue them with uh
with gas
and then they take them you know and
have them arrested accordingly the whole
question is how did things get to this
point you know
at what moment did everything seem to
change and what we're told or at least
what we're given is this sort of
uh quick rundown on the history of
wolverine's life what we know
is that before he joined the x-men
wolverine was a part of a group called
alpha flight as part of canada's
department k which was canada's
superhero team
the idea was that as part of alpha
flight you know wolverine served to
carry out government actions and so on
and so forth but eventually his journeys
brought him to the attention of the
x-men not only that he had of course
received his adamantium upgrades by
virtue of the weapon x program but in
light of all this
when the time came whereby he was made a
horseman of apocalypse
because the x-men either didn't come to
his aid or didn't arrive
fast enough that immediately after he
became the horseman war he
killed apocalypse right off the bat now
something to point out here is that this
is entirely possible apocalypse yes he
has
celesto technology yes he's wildly
powerful he's one of the most powerful
mutants in existence he can alter his
size to virtually anything
but wolverine having adamantium makes
him virtually
indestructible and because there's
really no metal
that that apocalypse could be in
possession of with the exception of
adamantium itself that could keep him
safe from wolverine
he was easily killed by wolverine now
this is also kind of funny too because
those of you guys who ever watched x-men
the animated series whenever wolverine
used his claws on apocalypse it never
worked that was actually an error that
was a mistake in the show
that uh his claws should have easily
torn through apocalypse's armor but the
fact remains here that after becoming
the horseman war he basically embarked
on a crusade to kill off
every single supervillain he came across
so he killed off the juggernaut he
killed
pyro he killed magneto he killed him all
he killed arcade who was a small time
villain that basically used tricks and
things like that he's like marvel's
version of the riddler but the fact
remains here
that he killed anybody he was much like
the punisher he killed anybody who was
involved in governmental corruption who
was involved in trafficking it didn't
matter if they were mutants it didn't
matter if they were humans if they were
political officials if they were your
average joes he killed
every single bad guy anyone who had ever
done anything nefarious in the marvel
universe the problem with this was that
the heroes also recognized that if
allowed to continue unchecked
that wolverine would basically become a
detriment to the world as a whole
and so all the superheroes of the world
came together and they began forming
their own governments their own or
against their own groups and
organizations so the avengers went
against wolverine the inhumans went
against wolverine the x-men went against
wolverine and he killed every single one
of them
he killed every last one and so in
response
the humanity and what was left of the
mutant population
banded together and formed a group
called war watch and warwatch was
designed to quite literally keep tabs on
what it was that wolverine was doing and
eventually find him and bring him in
the problem was that they were never
really successful in doing that simply
because of the fact that if wolverine
doesn't want to be caught then he won't
be caught and so what this does is this
continues along the path of one of these
young recruits who goes to the hudson
bay watch grounds which is kind of like
the next step
in the in the war wash not only that
he's also become a little bit
disillusioned with everything that's
going on
and so in his journeys he actually comes
across a a monk who seems to be in
hiding or the very least seems to be
just kind of watching all these things
unfold
and the idea is to learn from him
everything he can not only that
this person's operating under the mantle
of brother xavier so the initial idea is
maybe this is charles xavier maybe
charles xavier was the last surviving
guy
in addition to this what brother xavier
also does is he gives an account of
wolverine's history and saying that not
only you know did he turn against
various villains that he also fought
people who were allies at one point in
time again tying into this element of
killing off the uh the various
superheroes and the various
supervillains that existed and so in
response to this
basically what he did is he recognized
the fact that some aspect of his
personality the wolverine was always
doomed to be the horseman war that all
that you know becoming the horseman ward
did was allow this dark
aspect of his persona to completely
emerge and allow the humanity of who he
was to be cast aside and so in the end
what we learn is that this person that
this young man has been talking to
is actually wolverine himself in
addition to this once they get
you know back to normal society that
when the war watch is still trying to
deal with this gang this wolf pack
that's you know running amok
throughout various cities that wolverine
actually comes to their aid and
wolverine is able to stop
every single one of these kids not only
that this guy you know
some of these people also recognize that
it seems to be wolverine himself and so
once this meeting between the two is
completed once this young man
officially allows himself to be inducted
into the end of the order of
monks which are part of this uh this war
watch once he's become kind of a i guess
a leader so to speak that wolverine
officially reveals who he is and tells
him that the goal is to always keep
conflict at bay the goal is to always
keep battle at bay and then it's a
never-ending fight in order to achieve
this goal having said that i don't know
if you guys feel like i do this is one
of the worst written stories that i've
ever seen in the history of my life
this is so badly written it's not even
funny but it is still an interesting
concept with wolverine taking on the
entirety of the superhero and the super
villain community but because i don't
like to focus on the negative
we're going to bring this to an end but
post down in the comments let me know
try to be nice to each other guys try to
be civil post a comment down below and
let me know what you guys think about
this
story whether you thought it was good
whether you thought it was bad what you
thought the case may be and if you're
new here to comics explain make sure you
hit the sub button become part of the
rob core you may or may not get a shiny
new ring and
uh yeah make sure you guys drop a like
and i will catch you guys later
peace all right so one of the big
questions that i've had and this is
probably a video i'm going to release
before we really like jump into
christmas but one of the big requests
that i've had
is to make a video with naked related
content at least i'm pretty sure that's
how you pronounce it i'm pretty sure
it's deacon maybe it's dakin i don't
know
i was half inclined to call him steve
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that'd be an amazing title for a
video steve the son of wolverine
wolverine had a son named steve he's
like yeah man like he's just a tax guy
that's all he does is just do taxes he
didn't really have anything special
going on he's just kind of
just hanging out and then he screwed up
wolverine's taxes one day so he killed
him
[Laughter]
but um in any event i've been getting
that request a lot a lot of people
really like the character of dakin now
dakin as you guys know him was really
kind of fleshed out in
daniel way's run of wolverine origins
which is like this 50 issue run that
just covers like all these missing
memories of wolverine's life
as well as like original sin and
subsequent stories that came around
during that time but he was originally
introduced
under jeff loeb in wolverine volume 3
issue number 54
i think i'm not going to swear to that
but i'm pretty sure it's the case
somewhere around there somewhere along
those lines
but instead of like jumping into like a
whole volume of wolverine
and covering all these things that lead
up to the introduction of dakin only to
turn around and see a flop because
nobody really cares
what i instead wanted to do here was
basically go through and do the what if
story where wolverine killed his son now
what this does
is this basically kind of wraps around
into the early days of his life and it
turns history on its head a little bit
and what i mean here is
this story was written by a guy named
rob williams now as far as i know rob
williams really just kind of delved into
independent comics he really did a lot
of indie stuff and he's only really done
like a handful
of marvel comics and i think right now
he's working with dc and vertigo
but the idea here was that when deakin's
backstory was slowly revealed over the
course of a series of publications it
had been established
that his birth came by way of a massacre
to be honest the winter soldier bucky
barnes had basically been sent to kill
the pregnant wife of wolverine he
succeeded in doing that while wolverine
was gone
and then dakin was basically taken from
the corpse of his mother and then
dropped off
at a wealthy family's house and that was
really kind of like the earliest days
of dakin that's how he kind of grew into
that what this story does is it says
that didn't happen instead wolverine
basically came home
while itsu was being attacked she did
die but then he absolutely slaughtered
bucky barnes this is kind of a crazy
situation because
rob williams in his writing that's kind
of weird i wouldn't say it's continuity
errors so much that because this is a
what-if story this is not the same set
of events so what i mean here is for
those of you guys who are new to marvel
comics what ifs are usually like an
alternate reality
dc has else worlds where it's just like
here's a story where like batman and the
justice league become green lanterns but
they're not tied
into the main dc continuity it's not
like the ring of abin sure went to
bruce wayne instead of hal jordan and
that's the continuity it happens that
way but it's not tied into things with
marvel's what if
they tied into the main continuity so
they say well things progress normally
and then you know this event happened
and that seems to be what happens here
but the idea of wolverine killing bucky
barnes is kind of a big deal because
wolverine fought alongside
steve rogers captain america in world
war ii he fought alongside bucky barnes
as well and so he's basically killing an
ally
that he fought with during world war ii
the problem with this is that for
wolverine is pretty easy to distance
himself from the idea of i'm killing a
friend because this is after the
supposed death of bucky barnes when he
was taken by the russians and
transformed into the assassin known as
the winter soldier so because of this
the memories that he had of his former
life are essentially gone not only that
bucky barnes had never really faced an
enemy like wolverine before and that's
prevalent in this story when he's just
like you're not supposed to be here and
he's terrified for his life because
wolverine is a guy that after his claws
first popped you know after he took off
from his family and he basically tried
to live a peaceful life it was one of
these things where he just wanted to
stay out of the public eye he was like
the hulk he just wanted to be left alone
he wanted a peaceful life but woe be
tied the poor soul that came along and
screwed that up
and that's what happened with bucky
barnes he took the wrong contract
and the result is that wolverine
basically decapitates him now from here
the tough thing for logan is that he
literally has to cut his wife open
and take taken out and that's where
things start to differentiate because
and the main stories and again i'm not
going to get too deep into this on the
off chance this video is
stupidly popular people want me to do
dakin but essentially the story unfolded
in a different way to where an enigmatic
being basically came along some guy that
we didn't know who it was at first
came along and took daken out of his
mother's body and then dropped him off
with a family and so with wolverine
taking him for him
this is a crushing experience for logan
and this changes everything about his
character i mean this will impact his
role in the x-men
the whole nine yards because now he's
basically a father and that was really
daniel way's emphasis
when he said okay you know let's focus
more on dick and let's flush his
character out almost the entirety of
wolverine origins was this idea of
wolverine basically reflecting on the
history of his life and then i think by
issue number 10 dakin popped up and he
was like oh my god i'm a father and he
had to basically change his ways and
that's what happens here
he looks back at his life you know a
life of violence basically living for
the enjoyment of it sure you know he
killed people but he also wanted a
peaceful life but it was the idea that
wolverine could afford to be selfish he
was for all intents and purposes
immortal and so he knew in the back of
his head even if he didn't want to
acknowledge it that if itsu had a child
and the two of them raised it a time
would come that if that child did not
inherit
his healing factor he would outlive both
his wife and his son but for wolverine
that wasn't the issue it was he just
wants to have a normal life he just
wants to have a family he wants to be as
human as he possibly can
but looking at this child he basically
sits down and says i can't just live for
myself anymore it can't just be me
anymore now i've got someone that looks
up to me i effectively have to cast off
my old ways and i
literally just need to run to the
furthest corners of the world and that's
what they do they run to tibet i mean
they run to the third of the world and
they essentially just kind of hide out
there now the reason why tibet was
chosen is because it's such a difficult
place to get to i mean you've got to
get through the himalayas assuming you
can survive the experience and then
you've got to find your way to where it
is that they are
in tibet and so because of the fact it
is so isolated and so hidden
the likelihood of anybody who had
grudges with wolverine lady deathstrike
any of those characters nuke sabertooth
the likelihood of any of them
finding wolverine is slim to none and so
during this time he basically
raises his son as best he can he teaches
him prayer he teaches him the humble
nature of life he teaches him to respect
life to respect the value of all living
things to very much be
at home with himself the problem with
this is that
wolverine is effectively ignoring what
it was that made him who he was and this
is why rob williams writing is so good
is because
it begs the question is the violent
nature of wolverine just a part of who
he is
is it just his nature to be violent
there's a really really good parable
that i heard once called the scorpion
and the frog and any of you guys who
have heard this bear with me for a
second because a lot of people haven't
but it really represents these opposing
dichotomies of wolverine's desire for
peace and wolverine's inherent violence
the parable goes like this one day there
was a scorpion
sitting on the side of a riverbank one
day and he was trying to figure out how
to get across
and a frog happened by and the scorpion
said frog let me climb on your back
and you can set across the river and you
can drop me off on the other side and
the frog said no
no if i do that you'll sting me and i'll
drown
and the scorpion said why would i do
that if i did that then we would both
drown
and the frog thought about it for a
minute and the frog said well that's a
really good point you know okay that's
cool so the scorpion climbs on the
frog's back and the frog
sets off well halfway across the river
the scorpion's tail rears up
and stings the frog and while the frog's
veins are filling up with venom it looks
back at the scorpion and said why did
you sting me now we'll both drown and
the scorpion said i can't help it
it's in my nature and that's crazy thing
about the story is because
it's essentially this example where
wolverine's violent nature is who he is
it's a fundamental part of who he is to
ignore that to try to put it in a box
and hide it away in a closet means that
he's not recognizing the warning signs
initially that his son may be moving
that direction now by the time he begins
to pick these up it's too late and the
way that we learn that
is they're tending to their farm you
know there's of course a goat that
they're going to take care of and so on
and so forth but when wolverine goes
inside he asks a son he says what
happened to the goat and he says well it
seems like a predator got to it and
that's when wolverine begins to realize
that his son dagon is moving towards
this direction
of being such a violent individual
basically following the same path that
wolverine himself follow when he was
younger now from here we transitioned to
the introduction of charles xavier and
so this is rob williams saying hey even
if i don't give you a definitive
chronology of when these events take
place in terms of what's going on in the
outside world
here's some measure of how things take
place and so it works out really well
because the story's supposed to be
isolated i mean in truth this whole
first half is supposed to be removed
from all the events that are going on
and so we're not supposed to have this
tried and true understanding of when
this chronology takes place but when
xavier shows up of course wolverine's
like oh my god there's somebody here
because his first thoughts flash back to
weapon x you know all that kind of good
stuff and so he says you gotta go you
know get out of here you gotta go
and charles xavier essentially offers
him a chance to become part of the x-men
now
as we know with regards to the history
of the x-men and my explanation on the
x-men team and so on and so forth which
i need to get back into character and
team explanations but when charles
xavier showed up this was after
the original x-men of iceman and beast
archangel jean grey and cyclops had been
taken prisoner by the living island of
krakowa
and so this is essentially xavier
assembling a new team with colossus
nightcrawler the whole nine yards in
order to rescue the original x-men team
which is where that x-men title under
chris claremont began to grow from
but unlike the main earth 616 continuity
where wolverine says okay yeah sure i'll
join that instead he's like get out of
here
go away i do not want the outside world
interfering now the crazy thing about
this is
his son of course asks him says who was
that man what's going on wolverine muses
to himself he says well maybe i should
have told him it's a man from another
life maybe i should have told him it's a
guy from the outside world that leads a
school
where he wants to raise people that have
abilities to make sure their abilities
are used adequately
this is really wolverine with an extreme
amount of hubris because instead of
sitting down and saying well maybe this
guy charles xavier knows what he's
talking about
maybe the xavier school for gifted
youngsters maybe that's the place that
degan needs to go to because maybe being
among his own peers
will help him to better understand his
own role if there's a yin and a yang if
he's not around people
that don't have healing factors and that
don't have advanced combat skills and
that don't have
claws then it gives him this sort of
false sense of how strong he is but if
he
is around people that are just as
capable as he is they could simply just
shut down his mind instead of fighting
then it helps him to understand this
place because
this is really what deacon is
experiencing right now like all
teenagers all of us growing up we're
trying to understand where we reside in
this hierarchy of this social food chain
we're trying to figure out if we're
alpha males beta males we're trying to
figure out if we're alpha females beta
females we're trying to figure out where
we stand when it comes to our place
in the bigger picture but daikin has no
real challenges
it's almost like he's a predator in a
world of prey
and so because of this and we pick up
two years later and he ends up in a
monastery yes they're formidable in
their own right he's told you know by
the other kids around there they're
extremely capable in terms of fighting
but deakin doesn't take any of them
seriously because he has claws because
he has a healing factor he could kill
every last one of these guys no
questions asked he might sustain a few
bruises but his healing factor will take
care of all that
and so there's no counterbalance here
there's no one to challenge his
superiority and so it's grown and to the
point where he has
a very superior sense of self now this
comes to a head
when he begins talking to a woman named
indira now there's another kid that
steps up and this kid
dorji i think is how you pronounce it
i'm not sure exactly how to pronounce
that right but he basically says no no
and dear you do not have to counter this
guy you don't have to do whatever it is
that he wants you to do
we'll keep you protected and so what
happens is deakin challenges this dude
and
of course we end up picking up with this
kind of montage where rob williams
bounces back and forth where wolverine
takes off for a time and he tells his
son you're not to leave the property or
to attend the land do your chores if i
find out you've done anything other
there's going to be hell to pay when i
get back but we also learned that during
this fight
really degan had beat this kid within an
inch of his life not only that he had
dished out some severe
physical injuries in terms of cuts and
so on and so forth now this is rob
williams unofficially telling us dakin
has the use of his claws because up
until this point we didn't really know i
mean we didn't know if those had
manifested at all and it's kind of cool
that it happens behind the scenes it's
also kind of interesting the first use
of his claws here are in a very violent
conflict at least as far as we know
but because of all this people are
terrified of him people are horrified of
them and this comes to fruition
when you know we really have deakin just
kind of hanging out on the side of a
mountain and then indira comes to see
him and says
everybody wants you guys to leave
they're terrified of you they're
horrified of you they see you as a
violent insane psychopathic animal and
they're afraid you're going to kill
everyone and so the only way for them to
cope with that is to ask you to leave
and so you know he initially says i
don't really want to
but in the midst of their discussion
they're suddenly met with the arrival of
sabertooth now again
the saber-tooth in this story is just as
much a physical as a metaphorical
representation of wolverine's sins
coming back to haunt him and the reason
why i say that
is because saber tooth being a physical
presence has always been a part of
wolverine's life for as long as he can
remember going back to his time as team
x so on and so forth not only that saber
tooth is just pure bloodlust i mean
sabretooth just
loves killing people he has no real
connection with his own humanity and so
he has no real connection with anybody
else's humanity and because of this of
course the first thing he does is cast
indira aside and send her flying off the
side of the mountain to her death but
then he turns and looks to deacon and
says i'm trying to get wolverine but i
can
smell him on you i can tell you are his
offspring and so he says the best way to
get to him
is to get to you now dakin fights off as
best he can and he's actually pretty
impressive here
it's actually pretty cool to see him
hold his own to a degree against
sabertooth but what he's doing is he's
basically fighting experience he's
fighting a guy that has a
vast amount of experience in all forms
of combat and so try as he might he's
really got
nothing against saber tooth which of
course leads to the return of wolverine
who steps in now again this is really
kind of a funny situation but the issue
with this is that where wolverine is
successfully able to basically kill
sabertooth or at least it seems like it
here we basically jump forward a bit
to what deakin was doing now rob
williams does not give us like this
in-depth
explanation instead he just kind of fast
tracks it off then he tells us that you
know following the death of indira dakin
had basically gone to the monk monastery
and
slaughtered them all and this was
effectively his downward spiral because
in every story that's what happens right
i mean when you have like a villain or
you have
like a villain who is a good guy at some
point in time there's always that darth
vader effect you know there's a point
where they stop being a good guy and
they start being a bad guy
sometimes it takes a long time for that
transition to happen but that switch
eventually takes place
and this is the switch for dakin this is
where he stops being anakin and becomes
darth vader this is where he stops being
the son
of you know wolverine and becomes a bad
guy and so because of this he basically
takes off to tokyo
nine years after all this had happened
and forms a criminal empire for himself
to the point where he
basically has anything he wanted to now
he built this empire through
fear blood and death but he was able to
build it nonetheless the problem with
this
is that once wolverine finally locates
jake and after tracking him down for so
long he says look i'm going to offer you
the opportunity to stand down
like you you have to give up here you
have to stop this come back home with me
live a life of peace we can leave all
this behind us and we can call it a day
what's ironic about this
is wolverine still not learning he's
still not learning the fact that you
just can't run away you can't run away
from your problems you got to face him
head-on
dakin is a representation of wolverine's
failures dakin is representation of the
fact that wolverine believed he could
take his darker nature put it in a
corner and act like it didn't exist it's
everything that wolverine about his
youth coming back to haunt him and so
because of this you know dagon lashes
out and wolverine responds
in kind by saying i brought a muramasa
blade now for those of you guys who are
new
to marvel comics there are several
different aspects several different
weapons
that can defeat people who have healing
factors carbonadium can disrupt healing
factors temporarily but it's really
more like putting healing factors in a
state of flux so much as
turning them off the muramasa blade
turns off healing factors temporarily
and so when a person is touched by a
mirror muscle blade their healing factor
essentially stops working for a
temporary amount of time
effectively making them human they can
be killed by any normal conventional
means now when it comes to people who
have healing factors the caveat is that
unless you were to like cut off their
head or unless you were to
remove their heart or something like
that do something that would basically
keep their body from functioning in a
normal capacity
they're always going to come back after
the effects of the muramasa blade wear
off now we do not see that to its
fruition here instead
rob williams effectively kind of cuts it
off with the idea that wolverine was
forced to kill his son but this is
really wolverine finally recognizing is
him finally learning
that the mistakes that he made in his
life the things that he screwed up were
an indication of the fact that he was a
guy that could never find peace
wolverine could never live the life that
he was hoping for he wanted a kid he
wanted a life of happiness he wanted to
be left alone but the mistakes that he
made the things that he'd done were
always going to come back to haunt him
they were always going to be a part of
his life and ultimately dakin was a
representation of the fact that
wolverine again
cannot have a regular normal average
life like a human he was born a killer
and he will die a killer and that's just
how his life exists but if you guys are
new here to comics explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button
to become part of the rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like
and yeah leave a comment down below let
me know whether or not you guys are
interested in more digging stuff
and uh i will catch you all later peace